pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est par un pèlerinage à douaumont que
le général de gaulle a voulu commencer
son voyage en lorraine le 13e qu'il
effectue à travers la france d'où homo
ces quatre cent mille morts et le temps
qui a passé reste sans effet sur un
pareil chief de verdun ce devait être
durant quatre jours la visite à toute la
lorraine à bar-le-duc à epinal comme
tout au long de ce voyage la chaleur de
l'accueil fait au chef de l'état l'a
disputé à la chaleur tout coup
20 soit en cinq jours le général de
gaulle a pris la parole vingt fois il a
traité du problème algérien et comme à
nancy
il a évoqué les rapports d'associations
qui comporte la compréhension des
communautés à l'intérieur et l'appui de
la france à metz
avant de serrer les mains tendues le
général de gaulle avait encore affirmé
l'association est aujourd'hui la
solution du bon sens au cap canaveral
l'armée de l'air américaine en lançant
au moyen d'une seule fusée trois
satellites d'un coût a réussi un exploit
exceptionnel
l'ensemble pèse 500 tonnes et mesure 24
mai
au moment où la vitesse orbitale
atteignait 26 mille kilomètres
l'explosion a été déclenchée et les
trois d'une artificielles devaient se
séparer pour se placer sur une orbite à
une altitude d'environ 9 125 kg mais aux
dernières nouvelles
deux d'entre elles sont restées solides
est le premier satellite est destiné à
mesurer les rayons x du soleil le
deuxième satellite est chargée de
mesurer les radiations qui entoure le
globe terrestre
le troisième satellite alimentée par une
batterie nucléaire est destiné à l'étude
des télécommunications et naviguera
pendant une cinquantaine d'années
[Musique]
koweit est aujourd'hui le nom de
nouveaux points névralgiques du globe au
moment où il venait d'accéder à
l'indépendance
l'ancien protectorat britannique s'est
vu l'objet des visées annexionnistes du
général kasem de la cette manifestation
de la foule venue proclamer la volonté
de l'émirat de demeurer indépendant
là aussi l'appel de l'émir à l'aide
militaire britannique
producteur de pétrole du monde koweit
n'a pas fini de faire parler de lui
en france malgré la table ronde
les agriculteurs ne pas désarmer le midi
a obtenu à son tour a expérimenté la
technique des barrages ce qui le soleil
et d'un n'a pas toujours convaincu les
automobilistes et autres conducteurs de
camions de la correction du procédé et
manifestants n'en avait pas moins leurs
supporters et la honte désormais
traditionnel détracteurs est allés bon
train dans la région de château renard
qui est le premier marché européen
déprimé
on a compté près de cinq mille tracteurs
au pont de beaune ya sur la durance
face à ces déploiements il ne restait
aux touristes que d'essayer la marche
arrière ou la patience et de rêver avec
nostalgie à la trêve prônée par les
dirigeants des fédérations agricoles
le mécontentement paysans persiste la
route des vacances demeurent coupées
[Rires]
à flins les raisons de mécontentement
était différente les ouvriers ont trouvé
porte close
la régie renault pour réagir contre la
grève perlée avait décidé un lock out
qui devait d'ailleurs ne durer qu'une
journée
après quelques hésitations les ouvriers
devaient pourtant finir par adopter la
technique paysanne faute de tracteurs
ils ont quand même barré la route en
s'asseyant dessus
[Musique]
l'époque des vacances c'est aussi celle
qui est choisie pour effectuer les
travaux les plus importants de la voirie
parisienne
de sorte que le pari d'été apparaît
comme un vaste chantier dans ce paris là
le tourisme devient une petite aventure
qui demande autant de sang froid que de
persévérance
[Musique]
singulier paris que celui ci avec ces
trous ces débris qui brûle et ses
barrières
à
l'hôtel de sens l'un des plus
remarquables du marais est ainsi devenu
pratiquement inaccessible à moins d'être
un gymnaste distinguer le génie de la
bastille simple trôner sur un chantier
de construction
et les touristes pourront toujours cette
année de l'acharnement qu'ont semble
avoir mis à multiplier les pièges sous
leurs pas oui un bien curieux paris
[Applaudissements]
une tradition des saintes veut que la
saison parisienne trouve son apothéose à
versailles avec le bal des débutantes
elle était cette année près de 200
jeunes filles du monde françaises et
étrangères qui pour leurs 18 ans ont eu
l'honneur de faire la révérence devant
la princesse napoléon
[Musique]
cascades de robes lumineuses signé des
grands noms de la haute couture etc l'un
des bijoux sourire une brillante entrée
dans le monde qui eut aussi le mérite de
faire apprécier ses jeune fille bien née
les plaisirs de la danse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
35 degrés à l'ombre c'est une
température de vacances aussi la vie à
paris s'était notablement engourdi pour
prendre un rythme estival à l'heure du
premier rush vers les plages et la
montagne
pendant ce temps les gars étaient
littéralement assiégé 200000 parisien
ils sont partis en trois jours
à l'occasion de ces départs le train
auto couchette s'est intégré un peu plus
à la tradition des vacances la sncf a
mis en service sur la ligne paris
biarritz un nouveau train d'automobiles
accompagné qui prend en charge les
véhicules en même temps que les
voyageurs une solution originale sans
aucun doute qui permet tout en gardant
pour ainsi dire sa voiture sous la main
d'oublier les soucis de là
[Musique]
dans le même temps le chemin de la côte
d'azur s'est raccourcie par l'ouverture
dans sa totalité de l'autoroute estérel
côte d'azur qui est la première
autoroute française à péage il convient
de noter que sa construction qui a duré
cinq ans a coûté 22 milliards d'anciens
francs
désormais grâce à ses 63 km d'autoroute
on n'est pas pour ce parcours moitié
moins de temps gain appréciable pour les
vacanciers pressé d'arriver à la mer et
ils le sont toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
record battu pas celui du circuit b
celui des températures le thermomètre a
failli ne pas résister à la chaleur
les pilotes non plus et les voitures
encore moins celle qu'on l'attendait à
l'arrivée les ferrari du sinn se sont
rapidement des pouilles menés après un
départ tambour battant et finalement
c'est tout de même une ferrari celle de
l'italia baguette ti qui anime les
preuves
pourtant pas getty les blacks pour faire
de la figuration intelligente en
quelques tours de circuit
il devient une vedette une vedette qui
doit se battre jusqu'au dernier tour
avec les deux porsche de bonnier et de
l'américain coeur né pendant des
kilomètres et des kilomètres
c'est un chassé-croisé incessant entre
les trois voitures à près de 200 à leur
dernier tour bonnier est out plus que
deux bolides pour la première place une
première place qui se joue au sprint
comme dans une course cycliste
mais à deux cent soixante dix à leurs
bagues et ya gagné ses galons de grand
pilote
[Musique]
moi d'athlétisme des six nations à paris
au stade de colombes il ya là l'italie
l'allemagne la belgique les pays-bas la
suisse et la france départ du 100 m
c'est l'italien beyrouth il champion
olympique du 200 m qu'il grand favori il
gagne devant le français de les cours et
l'allemand gamplay michel macquet le
capitaine de l'équipe de france monsieur
muscle lance le javelot à 77 mètre 93 il
pas le recordman du monde l'italien
liévore et essai le quinze 100 m bernard
veut prendre sa revanche sur le belge
ben qui est en tête pour le moment
verlaine s'échappe dans la dernière
ligne droite
mais bernard revient et finalement gamme
soutien semble
allah
idriss de mettre 4 échoue de peu
quelques instants plus tard à 2 m eur
[Musique]
enfin pl 5000 mètres où le français
baugé rencontre l'amant flos bape
[Musique]
roger est en tête dans le dernier virage
mais flashback leur monde et remporte ce
samedi m finalement l'allemagne remporte
ce tournoi des six nations
[Musique]
magasins fermés mais aussi rideau de fer
arraché c'est alger durant la journée de
la grève des musulmans contre la
partition les vingt-huit mille hommes du
service d'ordre ont empêché que cette
journée soit une journée dramatique
comme ce fut le cas dans certaines
autres localités d'algérie
[Musique]
un instant à rabat le leader du fln
ferhat abbas et l autre du roi du maroc
hassan ii visite au terme de laquelle
les deux hommes ont affirmé que les
délimitations territoriales entre le
maroc et l'algérie les concerner seul
[Musique]
en tunisie le gouvernement avait choisi
ce moment pour relancer la sphère de
l'évacuation de be there le néo destour
avait mobilisé ses troupes pour
manifester dans la vie
[Musique]
à marseille l'arrivée des hommes de la
11ème division légère d'intervention
retirer d'algérie traduisait sur le plan
militaire la volonté de détente de la
france
[Musique]
paris a si l'on peut dire depuis
longtemps dépassé sa banlieue et les
années qui viennent verront notamment à
l'ouest grossir démesurément la grande
banlieue dès à présent la gare saint
lazare qui traîne tout l'ouest de paris
à peine chaque matin à suffire mais que
dire de la station correspondante du
métro par où toute cette foule sm à
travers la capitale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ainsi c'est affirmer la nécessité d'une
grande voie transversale souterraine est
ouest capable de déverser cinquante
mille usagers par heure au coeur même de
paris en résorbant l'engorgement de
salazar ce métro express qui roulera un
jour à 30 mètres souparis doublera le
grand axe routier qui passe par les
champs elysées il aura l'avantagé de
desservir le rond-point de la défense ou
un prodigieux ensemble administratif
s'intégrera un jour prochain au pari de
demain
il faudra attendre dix ans avant que les
maquettes du métro express qu'à admirer
le ministre des travaux publics soit
entrée dans la réalité c'est que le coup
de pioche de monsieur buron qui a ouvert
les travaux de la traversée souterraine
de la scène représente quelques 250
milliards d'anciens francs le prix de la
traversée de paris à 100 km heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
cet été les fruits se trouveront aussi
bien sur la table que sur la tête
c'est ce qu'on pourra constater en
allemagne ou la nana la pêche et les
bananes ont été promus au rang de
diadèmes pour les soirées très habillé
[Musique]
il va toi qu'on ne sera pas en reste
d'originalité à l'heure de la plage les
chapeaux très parisien de rigaud donne
le ton dans ce domaine où la règle
semble être de frapper les imaginations
[Musique]
les coiffures dans ces conditions ne se
refuseront pas une certaine recherche
certaines complications comme dans ses
modèles de carita ou le simple certaines
peut faire place ici encore à une grappe
de raisin
[Musique]
de la plage de l'isle-adam aux plages de
l'océan de la manche ou de la
méditerranée un même mot d'ordre donc
dans cet été fantaisie d'abord la
fantaisie il fallait s'y attendre c'est
à saint tropez qu'elle pouvait le mieux
donner toute sa mesure
côté féminin la règle admet cette année
qu'on soit abondamment vêtu pourvu qu'on
laisse apparaître la taille avec toute
la générosité voulu
[Musique]
à
côté masculin on persiste à essayer de
lancer la tenue habillée par excellence
le slip ou le short queue de pie avec
noeud papillon de rigueur
[Musique]
quant aux célébrités du cru on les
retrouve comme sacha distel à l'épi
plage ou le barman installé ses tables
dans l'eau ou bien encore au lieu-dit la
poêle à frire ou les amateurs de
bronzage total passe ainsi des heures à
rocky cétacés dernière occupation que ce
livre par exemple
françoise fabian avec tout cela on
comprendra que saint-tropez soit le
rendez-vous par excellence des curieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
constatons que les mauvaises langues ont
tort il y a aussi des pudeurs farouche à
saint tropez
[Musique]
un van gogh de bronze de trois mètres
veillé par le sculpteur zadkine a
parcouru paris comme pour un triomphe
antique
c'est un triomphe tardif si l'on songe
que chaque tableau de van gogh sont
aujourd'hui des millions et qu'aucun ne
trouve pas d'acheteur de son vivant
[Musique]
au bout de ce voyage la petite église
d'auvers sur oise
l'un les admirateurs du peintre maudit
viennent aujourd'hui à la recherche de
ses derniers souvenirs l'hôtel où il
vécut les derniers temps d'une vie
tourmentée
une minuscule chambre sous les toits une
lampe un cruchon un pauvre lee c'est en
ces lieux toujours hanté par son nombre
d espérer que les amis d'auvers ont
voulu que soit érigée la statue du
hasard team une statue qu aurait sans
doute aimé van gogh
[Musique]
lélio police des grecs et des romains la
bécade et arabes
baalbeck par delà le pittoresque d'une
femme voilée ou d'un homme porteur d'eau
est au liban une de ces sites est bénie
des dieux où l'imagination de l'homme
contemporain peut embrasser les siècles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les restes grandiose des temples que
rome a bâti à baalbeck peuvent alimenter
sans fin la méditation intimement mêlés
aujourd'hui au souvenir de la
civilisation arabe
les vestiges de l'oeuvre romaine compte
parmi les plus impressionnants du monde
[Musique]
la porte du monument du temple de
bacchus le plus grandiose qui est
laissée l'antiquité les landes
majestueux des colonnes qui ont résisté
aux tremblements de terre et aux
déprédations des hommes notamment les
six colonnes restée intacte du temple de
jupiter les plus hautes qu'on ait jamais
élevé témoigne de ce que fut l'ambition
de rome faire de baalbeck le premier
sanctuaire d'orient
[Musique]
de l'étoile à la concorde la foule
parisienne a clamé l'armée française
rarement une foule aussi nombreuse ne
s'étaient rassemblées pour assister à la
traditionnelle revue militaire du 14
juillet
[Musique]
mais pas
onze mille hommes 546 engins blindés et
motorisé devaient défiler devant le
général de gaulle contours et les
membres du gouvernement et pour la
première fois une place dans le défilé
était réservée aux engins téléguidés
français sortent d'obus venant capable
de transporter une charge d'explosif
éventuellement atomique
premier signe visible d'un
renouvellement de la force française
mise au rythme des moyens modernes
[Musique]
en donnant ordre les unités
traditionnelles terminé le défilé et les
acclamations qui les saluer avait un
sens
comme elle exprimait un voeu celui de
l'unité du pays et celui de la paix
recherchée et bientôt espérons le
retrouver
le nom de lénine écrit dans le ciel en
lettres fait de chasseurs à réaction a
marqué le début de la grandiose fête
aérienne au cours de laquelle le
gouvernement soviétique a présenté aux
moscovites enthousiaste sa nouvelle
flotte aérienne
les personnalités parmi lesquels on
reconnaissait monsieur khrouchtchev au
milieu de ses ministres et les membres
du corps diplomatique au grand complet
ont assisté au défilé de plus de 300
appareils dont une cinquantaine de type
encore jamais aperçu par les
observateurs occidentaux
qu'il s'agisse de chasseurs déconnante
en chandelle pour disparaître presque
instantanément dans les nuages d'avions
gros porteurs à turbopropulsion ou à
réaction transportant des engins
téléguidés de grandes dimensions ou de
bombardier les ga tuyères capable de
vitesse supersonique
c'est tout un arsenal nouveau qui devait
être une révélation
il est évident a pu déclarer un expert
américain que l'urss à moderniser tous
ces types d'avions il nous faudra deux
ans pour rattraper notre retard
c'est ce qui a conduit le gouvernement
de monsieur kennedy a réévalué ses
besoins militaires et en particulier a
fixé à 700 le nombre des bombardiers
b-52 indispensable pour fournir la
puissance de bombardements nécessaires
au cours des années à venir
[Musique]
dans la baie du vieux port de gaza est
la flotte italienne a reçu la visite du
président de la république monsieur gros
qui venus célébrer le 100e anniversaire
de la marine nationale dont la création
fut décrétée en 1861 lors de la prise de
la ville
dernier bastion du royaume de naples
[Musique]
en donne l'ordre les belles unités de
cette flotte composée surtout de
croiseurs légers et de destroyers ont
salué le passage du bâtiment qui portait
le chef de l'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous ces bâtiments aux lignes modernes
n'effaceront tout de même pas cette
vision d'un autre âge le navire école
des cadets un merveilleux voiliers où
les lignes deux gabiers le long des
verbes rappelé est un temps où la terre
était aux yeux de la pérouse et du
capitaine cook infiniment plus vaste qu
aujourd'hui
parce que dans le même temps londres a
fait un accueil chaleureux au soviétique
youri gagarine le premier homme du
cosmos
tout le long de la route qui l'emmenait
de la mer smith à l'ambassade soviétique
des milliers de londoniens ont acclamé
le voyageur de l'espace qui devait être
reçu par le chef du gouvernement
monsieur macmillan et également par la
reine elizabeth
ces seize siècles d'histoire convient de
célébrer à ligugé et que résume en plein
poitou l'abbaye qu'on dit le plus ancien
monastère d'occident c'est là qu'au 4ème
siècle
vint s'établir en ermite le grand saint
martin pour y fonder ensuite la première
communauté religieuse des fouilles
entreprises récemment ont découvert les
restes des premiers établissements qui
raconte l'histoire de cette abbaye créé
au dessus de l'ermitage du sein le plus
populaire des gaules avec les pavages du
7e siècle avec les fenêtres jumelées du
même temps sauf quelques un tract
l'abbaye de ligugé est resté
jusqu'aujourd'hui fidèle à sa mission à
travers les restaurations comme à
travers les avatars de l'histoire elle a
continué à vivre selon la règle que lui
avaient tracé son fondateur
aujourd'hui comme voici seize siècles
des moines se livrent ici aux travaux et
aux recherches qui sont la gloire et la
vie de l'europe travaux qui font de
chacun tour à tour des épuise signé en
corvée de patates et des jardiniers qui
savent allier la beauté des parterres au
rendement du potager
[Musique]
ce qu'ils font aussi des érudits dont
l'un à l'aide d'une bibliothèque qui
compte parmi les plus copieuse et les
plus variés élabore la soutenance d'une
thèse théologique et dont l'autre
approfondie un chapitre de sciences ou
d'histoire l'étude fait bon ménage avec
le travail manuel name à ces recherches
certains l technique et travaux
artistiques l'oeuvre des anciens et
mayer a trouvé ici des continuateurs
[Musique]
et les journées depuis 16 cents ans se
suit mêlant les labeur quotidien mail
entacheront et ce avant sous le voile
permanent d'une prière ici des moines
priait au 4e siècle de notre ère à la
même place d'autres moines en 1961
travail est pris
une leçon d'éternité
tout le monde attendait l'offensive de
charlie gaulle dans la grande étape des
pyrénées superbagnères pour mélange de
la montagne avait perdu ses ailes dans
le brouillard s'était régional marcel
kaki s'échapper attaque seul le
tourmalet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marcel quéheille passe des tâches et le
col du tourmalet
[Applaudissements]
et elle est toujours en tête dans
l'ascension du deuxième grand col de
l'étape l'aubisque et il franchit devant
un autre régional le 115 bus tôt
[Applaudissements]
pour
béria gueye et buste haut et petit
groupe de coureurs dont le belge pauwels
numéro 30
même la chasse
à pau victoire du belge de health
[Musique]
la 21e et dernière étape du tour de
france ramène les rescapés à paris
jacques anquetil qui veut terminer en
beauté s'est échappé en compagnie de
quelques coureurs
[Applaudissements]
à l'arrivée au parc des princes anquetil
lance cazals victoire de cazala l'étape
victoire d'un style victoire complète
des français qui cette année était
vraiment les plus forts
comme chaque année à la saint firmin la
feria de pampelune dans nos jeunes
espagnols l'occasion d'éprouver leur
courage blue des réjouissances
populaires on lâche les taureaux dans la
rue les impôts suivant les autres
taureaux et jeunes gens arrivent dans
l'arène où ils vont s'affronter
le jeu consiste à éviter les charges des
bêtes furieux les cornes sont en boulet
mais le jeu à ces risques
malheur aux maladroit
pendant que la reine se vident des
courageux essaie de détourner les
taureaux acharné sur la victime
[Applaudissements]
un seul blessé grave les autres avaient
sans doute la protection de saint firmin
après cinq semaines d'interruption les
conversations dicte d'evian ont repris
au château de lugrin tous voisins cette
fois on a donc vu reparaître transporté
par hélicoptère
monsieur belkacem krim à la tête de la
délégation du fln et monsieur louis joxe
chargé de diriger les débats du côté
français les délégations ont abordé la
discussion par la recherche d'une
méthode de travail mais ce débat de
procédure est parsemé d'obstacles
la mairie de vient de rééditer l'exploit
du commandant shepard second cosmonautes
virgil grissom et très dans la capsule
spatiale d'une nouvelle fusée redstone
pour faire un nouveau bond dans le
cosmos à plus de 8000 kilomètres à
l'heure la fusée est monté jusqu'à 190
km pour retomber à 488 km de distance
la caméra a pu saisir l'instant où la
capsule s'est détachée de son support
pour tomber dans l'atmosphère
voyage a duré seize minutes
un porte-avions croisette à l'endroit
prévu pour la mairie singes et ses
hélicoptères ont rapidement découvert la
capsule qu'il devait récupérer par
malheur le relevage a été une première
fois manqué et cette erreur a eu comme
résultat la perte de la capsule sombré
par 500 mètres de fond et d'un forcé
pour virgil grissom
et
on pouvait redouter que l'agitation
entreprise par le président bourguiba au
début de juillet produisent des
incidents on sait maintenant ce qui en
est résulté
et donnant un tour aigu à ses
revendications sur la base de bizerte
occupée selon des conventions régulière
par la france celui qu'on donnait pour
un homme politique avisé et prudent est
arrivé au drame
on sait ce qu'est be there un goulet 3
qui mène de la mer au lac intérieur
rades magnifique et sûr vous pourrez
évoluer toute une flotte
puis une ville établi sur les bords du
goulet et qui a donné son nom à
l'ensemble
enfin la base navale créé par la france
au centre de la méditerranée la position
de bizerte est primordiale puisqu'elle
commandes de détroit de sicile
cette importance a suscité le destin de
bizerte où les installations de la base
en noir sur la carte sont dispersés sur
les rives du lac
ces installations en dehors même de
l'amirauté aider point de mouillage des
bâtiments comportent tous les services
annexes d'un porche atelier à saint
magasin caserne hôpital et un aérodrome
dont la piste devait être allongée de 2
à 3 mètres
ce projet monsieur bourguiba le
transforma en défi il décida de bloquer
la base de bizerte
des milliers de volontaires civils
requis par le néo destour commun certes
à creuser des tranchées à établir des
barrages
interrompant ainsi la libre circulation
entre les services de la base répartis
autour du lac
autour de l'aérodrome on est habitant
réseau de tranchées et des emplacements
pour l'installation de mortier de canaux
l'épreuve de force déjà ce discernait
l'opinion tunisienne chaque jour chauffé
par une propagande incendiaires suivez
le chemin dangereux tracée par son chef
et l'on en arrive à une manifestation
organisée devant l'ambassade de france
ou même les femmes enrégimentés va
prêter un premier concours avant d'être
employé comme on devait le voir plus
tard aux barricades
rni souvent de province éloignée
d'autres volontaires très jeune pour le
plus grand nombre est parfaitement
encadré ce mirta leur marge sur viseur
pour achever le blocus
il n'était pas question pour les
français de céder sous la menace et les
positions de combat prises par les
unités de l'armée tunisienne et les
volontaires armés qu'on lui avait juin
confirmait la volonté tunisienne
d'engager par les armes
ce que monsieur bourguiba nommé déjà la
bataille de bizerte
un avion français et essuyé bientôt le
feu des tunisiens mais quatre heures
devait passer et de nouveaux tirs se
succéder avant que l'amiral anne en chef
de la baz décide de répondre
du porte avions à rallonge croisant au
large les premiers avions étaient alors
dépêché pour dégager les abords de
l'aérodrome
puis nous approche de l'amirauté la
cimenterie utilisée par les troupes
tunisienne comme base d'actions était
neutralisée
il restait à dégager les accès de la
base et à assurer la libre circulation
dans le poulet part et par les tunisiens
c'est ce que devait accomplir les unités
de parachutistes
il
et
les opérations se terminait par un
nettoyage des terrasses ou des isolés ou
des bandes plus ou moins contrôlés tiré
du haut des immeubles
le soir tout était fini on pouvait
dénombrer le matériel de toutes
provenances priaulx tunisie
e
puis la mire à la main faisait replacer
les couleurs tunisiennes sur les
bâtiments officiels
au même instant le conseil de sécurité
écouter le délégué français monsieur
armand bérard aucune puissance ne
ressent plus douloureusement que la
france
les événements aussi regrettable trop
grave sur lequel le conseil porte
aujourd'hui son attention et dont la
responsabilité n'incombe en aucune
manière à mon pays le gouvernement
français a déjà marqué dans les
communications faites par le chargé
d'affaires de france le 13 et le 16
juillet qu'une solution au problème de
bizerte ne saurait être recherchée dans
une atmosphère de passion ni sous la
menace de manifestations populaires
si au contraire la situation redevenait
normale sans menaces ni mise en demeure
une réponse serait adressée au message
que le président bourguiba a fait
remettre au général de gaulle 7 juillet
puis monsieur mongi slim donner la
version tunisienne de la faire elle
propose des négociations pour un cessez
le feu qui aux yeux du gouvernement
tunisien ne peut être acceptable que si
le principe de l'évacuation définitive
et immédiate est acquise en même temps
par conséquent sur le président la note
a été rejetée pour des raisons de forme
aussi bien que pour des raisons de fond
l'arrêt des hostilités permettrait
d'intérêt les cadavres
le drame avait fait 700 me il
permettrait de rétablir l'électricité et
l'eau que les parachutistes distribués
par les moyens du bord il permettrait de
rendre son visage à bizet
mais monsieur bourguiba croyait-il dire
si vraies tentes ayant consciemment
préparer lancée et allumer ce conflit il
parlait de cette guerre absurde de
bizerte
[Musique]